let me ask about nationalism which i
think is at the core of i want you
poster
is nationalism destructive or empowering
to a nation
and we can use different words like
patriotism which is in many ways
synonymous to nationalism but
in recent history perhaps because of the
nazis
has has
slowly parted ways that somehow
nationalism is when patriotism
pictures patriotism gone bad or
something like this yeah they're they're
different right um patriotism um
you know patriotism is in some ways best
thought of as an emotion right and a
feeling of of love of country right
you know literally
and in some ways that's a necessary
condition to participate in nationalism
you know whether
to me i think nationalism is
crucial
in a world organized around nation
states and you have to sort of believe
that you are engaged in a common project
together right um and so you know in the
contemporary united states uh you know
uh
in some ways that that question is
actually on the table in ways that it
hasn't been in the past
but you know you have to believe that
you're engaged in a common project that
you have something in common
with the person with whom you share this
nation um and um and that you would
sacrifice for them whether it's by
paying taxes for them or
um you know or going to war to defend
them
um that's a vision of you know what we
might call civic nationalism um
uh that's that's the good version
the question is whether you can have
that um without having
um
exclusionary nationalism you know hating
the other right fearing the other saying
uh yeah be you're part of this nation
against all others
and
i think there's a long tradition in
america of a very inclusive uh
nationalism um that is open
inclusive welcoming um
and you know new people to this year
project
um that's something to be defended
exclusionary nationalisms based on you
know
ethnic hatreds and and others that we
see throughout the world and those are
things to be afraid of
but there is a kind of narrative in the
united states that
a nationalism that includes the big
umbrella of democratic nations
nations that strive for freedom
and everybody else is against
is against freedom and against human
nature and it just so happens that it's
a half and half split
across the world
so that's imperialism
that feels like it beats the drum of war
yeah and i i mean i don't want to paint
too rosy a picture and certainly you
know the united states um as a nation
has often found it easier to define
ourselves against something
than to clarify exactly what we're for
yeah
yeah
the cold war
china today
that's not only united states i suppose
that's us human nature
it's we need a competitor it's almost
like
maybe the success of human civilization
requires
figuring out how to construct
competitors
that don't result in global war
yes or figuring out uh how to turn
enemies into rivals and competitors
there's a real difference
right you know you can you you know you
compete with competitors you you fight
with enemies
yeah with competitors is a respect maybe
even a love
underlying the competition
you